okay let's go to our caller from the 201
area code who's calling today from 201
hi David can you hear me yeah I can hi
thank you so much for the opportunity to
be on your show I really do appreciate
it and it's wonderful that you get calls
like my pleasure so I guess my first
question has to do with your stance on
abortion okay while I'm in the pro-life
or pro-choice ID and your justification
for it I'm pro-choice and I think that
abortion is a legal medical procedure
and it should be like other legal
medical procedures up to the people who
will be procuring that procedure to
decide whether it's a procedure that
they want okay
sure well I mean so I don't know if how
many different topics you have but feel
free to follow up oh thank you you say a
legal medical procedure and that the
person who's receiving the procedure
should be the one who decides that
they're allowed to get the procedure no
I don't say that no no no I didn't say
that the person who gets the procedure
should be allowed to decide whether
they're allowed to get it what I said is
that when you have you know heart bypass
or the lancing of a cyst or you know the
full list of medical procedures that are
legal there's a process by which the
patient consults with medical
professionals and they consult with
their family and they can do whatever
independent research they want to do and
ultimately they come to some conclusion
about whether that's a procedure they
want to go forward with or not and
you're saying that because I guess
abortion is a medical procedure that's
legal basis all sort of the same
criteria as all these other legal
medical procedures well yeah I mean
certainly there are people who say it
should not be legal right like so and
then in that case it's a totally
different question but your question to
me I as I understood it was what is my
opinion on it and and I'm responding on
the basis that I know that it's legal
since it
illegal that's my view if you want to
argue maybe it shouldn't be legal then
we can have a different conversation you
know oh that yeah that makes total more
sense I was just trying to sort of
clarify your position yeah I'm sorry if
I was a little unclear I'm talking about
the legality of abortion okay um and
just what your idea because there's a
lot of arguments in the pro-life side
which are that when there's an
externality things shouldn't necessarily
be legal and I guess I wanted to hear
you weigh in on the discussion yeah as
soon as they apply that to any other
area of socioeconomic life climate
change economics the financial industry
they it is I've not heard that defense
of the anti-choice movement before but
it's hilarious to me that the side that
systematically ignores externalities of
not regulating businesses not dealing
with climate change all of a sudden say
listen we're not thinking about the
externalities when it comes to abortion
I find that a laughable and specious
argument coming from the American right
okay but if you're even wasn't coming
from the American right it was coming
from an officer to the American left
would you take it more seriously well
then I would say let's don't
specifically discuss what externalities
you claim exists okay for sure so um the
I believe the anti-choice position as
you called it held that there's a
externality in that doing an abortion I
guess performing an abortion I'm is
morally equivalent to murder in that
murder is only the termination of a life
for the future of a life oh yeah I just
I think it's a very I mean so then we
get back into just debating whether it's
life or not and then you get into a very
sort of gray area where you know they
like to play this infinite regression
where it's like we'll listen if it's a
life at nine months then it's really
sort of a life at eight and a half
months and then it's sort of really a
life at eight months and then it's
really a life at seven and a half I mean
this is like I just find that these
arguments at their core are funded
biological I'm finding that it's a it's
an argument that at its core is
fundamentally illogical and also doesn't
really get us anywhere beyond just kind
of like hypothetical theoretical
arguments okay but a lot of these
arguments aren't theoretical they're
grounded in the fact that the pro-choice
movement as again I'm just repeating
claims yeah doesn't really have a
fundamental basis for what it considers
life so the development of life I guess
should continue until after birth yet
here's where I disagree and here's what
I disagree yeah I understand I
understand the assertion that that
you're making the reality is that a lot
of these reactionary arguments depend on
black and white distinctions that often
in reality don't exist okay think about
a speed limit you set the speed limit to
35 on a road does that mean that you
can't safely be driving 37 or 38 no does
it mean that 25 might be too fast if
conditions are icy no that could also be
the case there's nothing magical about
35 miles per hour but as a society
sometimes you have to sort of establish
some kind of infrastructure so I get
that they are arguing if you don't say
exactly which point in the development
of a fetus life begins they claim that
there's no sort of under arching
fundamental framework that says when
does life start and when is it not yet
life we live in a world where reality is
complicated and III don't have any
problem in the same way that I don't
have a problem with a speed limit being
35 even if that's not always the exact
safety limit of saying listen at four
weeks it's fine and at nine months it's
not and we've got to set someplace in
between this is what this is why just
focusing on principles doesn't actually
give you the answers for how society
should be run it's sort of like a case
study in in the problem with just
focusing on these principles and saying
the left has
principle for when left for when life
begins I just think these are not there
when I said theoretical I don't mean
these aren't real life issues I mean
that it's theoretical in terms of there
is not going to be consensus as to the
day in fetal development at which life
begins no I totally understand that
I'm very difficult to draw a line of
sand and sort of establish a fundamental
underlying framework and like Oh at like
four weeks in three days and two hours
especially since like fetal development
varies from view but in terms of your
speed limit example I'm the reason I
sort of peak issue with that yeah or I
guess other people with it I'm sort of
playing devil's advocate but sure I
guess the reason I was the issue with
that is that if you go beyond the speed
limit you don't actually kill anyone
speed limit is sort of just a government
plane force regulation - I disagree with
you I think that hold on a second I
actually think that that that's exact
thats very interesting the argument is
that when you go beyond the speed limit
it becomes unsafe and you actually could
kill someone and i understand that there
is a difference here in that the
pro-life movement says every abortion is
a murder where as part of the reason to
have a speed limit is to prevent people
from being killed they might be killed
they might not be killed I don't know
that it's as bad of an analogy as you're
suggesting although I completely concede
that it's not perfect the point I was
trying to make is that the hard line say
oh around here like say the speed limit
55 miles now we're going 70 miles an
hour wouldn't necessarily end in
anything that's true particularly
disastrous happenings um so the line in
the sand I guess legally to be drawn was
the probably as far back as possible in
order to ensure that life doesn't get
terminated after it develops okay sure
that makes sense okay I guess eating if
that makes sense would you be in favor
of a yes banning abortions after first
term for example after the FIR after the
first come on listen I'm
here's here's where I'm gonna I'm gonna
sort of stop the conversation in the
sense that it's not for me to determine
I'm not an expert on fetal development
so what I would do is I would leave it
up to doctors to determine that it's
just not my you know I'm not in the same
way that some right-wing Christian
ideologue is not an expert in fetal
development and shouldn't be making
these decisions I shouldn't either my
opinions basically irrelevant on that
mmm I mean it's also talk because
there's no consistent standard for long
life starts we don't even have a
standard for death we just have standard
for death in that we know after
someone's been dead they don't come back
though yes all right well listen it's a
very interesting discussion I'm gonna
let you go but I do appreciate you
calling in and it's an issue that we're
certainly going to be continuing to to
talk about and on that note my time for
live calls has expired thanks to
everybody who called in sorry to
everybody I didn't get to I will take
calls again